[Music]
first US shows in over a year I can't
believe it what's going through your
head I am so thrilled and so grateful I
mean this whole year has been wild you
know not being able to work in my own
country it's not the way it's supposed
to be here in America and you can hate
that picture all you want but it's very
much covered under the First Amendment I
didn't break the law okay if you don't
like a Halloween mask and catch up get
over it was there a moment where you
thought I'm not gonna work in America
again yeah there were a couple of days I
always say I was broken for two days
like you know I famously said I'm gonna
be honest he broke me he broke me he
broke me for two days then I got up and
started writing and working and plotting
and then I realized nobody had my back
so I was completely on my own it's been
a real rude awakening and then I just
left into action like back to my roots
nobody can stop me from a microphone and
my offensive jokes I went okay what made
me like what led to my biggest success
and I thought it was when I used to do
the Laugh Factory in Los Angeles and I
called the owner and I said what is your
worst time slot I'll take it and I
started you know just coming up material
I would do shows there and then people
would line up around the block and then
I started going okay I can do like
theatrical stand-up shows did you ever
think when the career kind of seemed
like it was falling apart did you think
personal life's gonna fall apart Tube my
personal life did fall apart I mean I
lost 90% of my friends and my joke is my
I'm down to eight gay guys - puppies my
boyfriend and my mom and my mom's on the
bubble so yeah my life got very pared
down and you know it was interesting the
comedian Katt Williams called me that
day and he said get out a pen and a
piece of paper write down the name of
every single person who calls you today
with complete support at the end of that
day look at the list and those are who
your friends are four three names who
are the three Kat Jim Carrey and by the
way let me just stop and say Jim Carrey
said something really vital it was today
you're the most famous comedian in the
world and I was sobbing and I go Jim for
all the wrong reasons he doesn't know
use it he goes you're gonna have
material that's so unique and personal
so it's Kat Jimin who is the
they're in the College of that day it
was my mom although it took me an hour
to convince her I wasn't a member of
Isis I mean that's my life you gotta
laugh yeah laugh at the it like I'm 57
telling my 97 year old mom that I have
not joined Isis and she kept calling at
a club
she kept why did you join that Club out
of all the clubs because I'm like mom
put the box of wine down and we'll talk
tomorrow
so I finally I finally won my mom back
had your pal Joan Rivers been around oh
you know she would have picked up the
phone that day yeah honestly I miss Joan
Rivers everyday she was besides a pal a
true mentor and you know one thing that
I learned from her was when the going
gets tough go tougher if you could go
back and do it again what yeah yes yes
and for a long time I was saying things
like no I wouldn't do it or I've even
said you know I would do it was like a
blow-up doll so people would really get
it and now I realize he really deserves
it like when Eddie Munster went on Good
Morning America and said she deserves
what's coming to her I'm like no [ __ ]
you deserve what's coming to you and
guess what's coming to you
me
[Music]
[Applause]